[Musique]
voilà une semaine que la france entière
est plongée dans une situation aussi
inédite que déroutante selva confinement
quasi totale et si rester chez soi ne
rien faire a pu sembler pendant
longtemps un rêve éveillé pour beaucoup
d'entre nous l'impossibilité de sortir
de son domicile et la perspective que
cela puisse durer encore longtemps n'est
pas toujours facile à gérer ainsi les
français s'organisent pour occuper leurs
journées
si certains continuent tant bien que mal
leur vie normale entre gestion des
enfants et télétravail d'autres se
retrouvent chez eux parfois isolés et au
chômage technique
un moment propice pour regarder des
séries ou se cultiver comme l'a
conseillé le chef de l'état mais aussi
pour conserver un lien social grâce aux
différents apéro virtuel que de nombreux
français ont adopté grâce aux appels
visio cette situation inédite n'est pas
toujours facile à gérer dans ce climat
angoissant les relations entre
colocataires amis ou compagnons peuvent
parfois s'avérer difficile à vivre en
chine
après plus d'un mois de confinement
sévère le nombre de demandes de divorce
a littéralement explosé un confinement
auquel nous n'avons jamais fait face et
pour lequel nos cerveaux ne sont pas
préparés alors selon vous le profil
manquent-ils fou
alors déjà on aimerait avoir l'avis du
docteur jean-paul hamon qui fait un
carton sur les réseaux sociaux je vous
le dis c'est notre nouveau héros tout le
monde voilà n'arrête pas de dire
j'espère que le docteur hamon va revenir
il reviendra continue et j'espère déjà
qui va qui va guérir et qui va sentir
mieux puisque je rappelle aux est
atteint ducobu 19 êtes chez vous un
confiné est-ce que vous avez des
solutions pour les français est ce que
le confinement peut rendre fou c'est le
confinement ça m'inquiète énormément
parce que joua les on a beaucoup
critiqué les parisiens qui sont partis
se réfugier en bretagne en normandie ou
à la campagne
mais bon parce que ça risquait de deux
diffuseurs russe
mais honnêtement quand vous êtes dans un
appartement avec deux et vous n'avez pas
le droit de sortir
là vous êtes au bord de la crise de
nerfs et puis et puis il va y avoir des
cartes des compensations il va y avoir
des cas de crises conjugales
certainement donc il faut mettre un
maximum d'humour maximum de parce que là
franchement je plains les gens qui qui
vont rester confiné parce qu'à mon avis
on en a encore jusqu'au mois de mai
jusqu'au mois de mai c'est ce qui est
annoncé raymond est avec nous apprendre
à florian ferreri psychiatre il va nous
dire 6,4 à l'hôpital saint-antoine
raymond moshiri est ce que tu penses que
ça peut rendre fou ce confinement toi il
a dix mois de mai le médecin
ouais il a dit vrai moi je vais devenir
fou moi je suis en train de devenir sous
gestion des peuples les habitudes ça
veut dire que moi enfin je travaille le
matin dès 5 heures du matin c'est à 20,2
à la je ne fais plus rien dessus à l'art
est potable je m'endors à 5h du mat je
me réveille hamiti et en plus c'est vrai
qu'on n'est pas tous égaux par rapport
au confinement
il ya des gens tous peuvent aller en
province ou qu'on desjardins qui peuvent
faire du télétravail directement dans
leur jardin et pita ceux qui sont avec
quatre gosses enfermés dans un
appartement que pour eux c'est très dur
aux déjà moi je galère syrie il était ma
route je me lève et d'un frigo regarde
par la fenêtre j'ai un moral soit avant
le canapé vous m'entendez ou pas en
tentant michelle obama on a aussi quatre
avec une psychiatre à l'hôpital
saint-antoine
c'est florian ferreri monsieur le
docteur
le docteur ferret ce qu'on peut tenir
pendant le confinement et comment tenir
à ce que vous avez des petites astuces
pour nos téléspectateurs
alors est-ce qu'on peut tenir oui
heureusement la nature humaine est
capable de tenir à ce petit défaut
le problème c'est qu'on n'est pas tous
égaux ça c'est sûr tempérament des
portes énergie mac sont plus calmes plus
speed pure n'est pas tous égaux dans les
conditions de vie qu'on a sur un
appartement une maison et je n'en sais
pas davantage les balais petit truc
c'est d'essayer de se faire un agenda et
de garder un certain rythme sinon ça va
être un enfer un supporter des journées
à rallonge ça a été dit à plusieurs
reprises essayé d'avoir des moments on
s'expose à la lumière malgré tout à la
fenêtre comme deux parce qu'on a
vraiment besoin de cette luminosité ça
ça va être une vraie conséquences sur le
moral et enfin tenter d'avoir une
activité physique ça et 3 étrangers
venus parce que la maison est vide en
faire le tour de la cuisine le tour
d'une assiette dans un truc comme ça il
faut faire des choix trouver des trucs
jean paul hamon presque penser tu peux
avoir plus de divorces est ce que les
coupes sont en danger
je sais pas mais j'ai vu dans matière
d'activités là le gars qui a fait un
marathon sur son balcon monde va lui
mettre de la fepaci vous l'avez vu on
l'a vu c'est sûr que si des gars ou été
capable de faire un marathon au board
dans le sur le balcon il ya peut-être
qu'ils peuvent en faire dans le salon où
j'en sais rien mais c'est sûr qu'il faut
que j'en trouve quelque chose pour se
défouler un petit peu se détendre parce
que c'est vrai que ça va pas être simple
surtout quand on est des enfants en bas
âge en plus il ya beaucoup de gens et je
voudrais dire à notre 6 4 qui est avec
nous il ya beaucoup de gens aussi qui
ondoie sur la suite qui disent on n'a
pas de travail
peut-être que comment ça va se passer
pour notre travail après est ce que
notre entreprise va va pouvoir exister
après ce coronavirus donc qu'est-ce que
ce qu'on a des des moyens aussi de leurs
voilà de leur dire voilà d'arrêter de
stressé parce qu'il ya beaucoup de gens
qui sont non seulement confiné il
stresse pour le corps humain d'un virus
il stresse pour l'avenir et stress pour
l'avenir de leurs enfants
est-ce que vous avez d'aidé technique
florian ferrier
ainsi seul la charge mentale elle aimait
entretenir la classe après classe c'est
pas évident se demander comment va
évoluer la maladie avoir un
désinformation et sur l'économie alors
que le procès de rester informés ça vous
y participer c'est important d'éviter
l'effet menace de rester informés après
c'est effectivement au de la dépense
physique il faut trouver des moyens
d'avoir des moments à soit leur âge
journée alors qu'en suède 15 28 et de
travailler sur ses pensées négatives sa
relaxation et d'essayer de le fait de
ceux de voyager en quelque sorte sans
quitter son appartement
donc c'est quand on a une pensée
négative qu'ils arrêtent et qui arriva à
l'esprit essayé soit soin de laisser
passer soit de la retenir et d'essayer
de la transe qu'envie de la positiver
peut paraître un peu un peu simple comme
conseil mais ça marche la vie et puis il
ya une petite vidéo sur youtube qui qui
explique aux gens comment modifier une
pensée qui nous préoccupe alors est-ce
que c'est dangereux de passer son
confinement tout seul est-ce qu'on peut
devenir complètement dans bsca ya plein
de gens qui me posent la question qui
nie moi je suis tout seul j'ai peut-être
devenir fou voilà entre quatre murs j'ai
un petit à part je peux pas sortir de
chez moi voilà est-ce qu'on peut devenir
fou alors sur un modèle expérimental sûr
mais quelqu'un va des cours du seul
essai dans tout le monde tout le monde
faisait devenir plus mais je pense pas
qu'on devienne fou comme ça sur le fait
des seuls parce que c'est vrai que c'est
confinement parle de confinement
d'isolement mais c'est plutôt on va dire
une distanciation physique on n'a pas ce
qu'on reste en pas qu'il ya des médias
il ya la possibilité de s'appeler donc
on est quand même en communication il ya
une vie sociale qui s'installe qui est
certes différente de d'habitude mais qui
s'installe quand même mais alors par
contre sont vraiment seul c'est
difficile avec on a vu qu'en chine il y
avait un boom des divorces est ce que
vous avez voilà un conseil à donner aux
couples pour ne pas divorcer parce que
c'est vrai qu'en chine après le
confinement ça a été un massacre aussi
haut niveau voilà d'aidé divorce à la
promiscuité irritabilité et de la
tension il ya du conflit c'est vrai que
avant de parler de d'éventuels conseils
on est quand même très occupée pour les
femmes qui sont seuls avec leur conjoint
qui peuvent être violents et on sait que
les exactes seront sûrement en ce moment
et là c'est un vrai sujet d'inquiétude
le l'idée c'est vraiment de trouver le
moyen dans une journée type de se
séparer parce que finalement on n'est
pas toujours les uns sur les autres on
sait pas forcément top simple ça peut
être la salle de bain ça peut être la
chance ou coordonnées dans le planning
de la journée à avoir des moments où
vous peut décompresser seul sinon c'est
impossible et pour ceux qui ont une
tension une charge psychique troubles
importants sont à parler on a parlé du
sport et vie ce qu'il n'y avait vraiment
pas avec son qui ensuite parce qu'on
peut en feu et essayer de les aider la
revue soit de techniques
comportementales soit certain nombre
d'objets de les traiter ceux qui sont
vraiment trop impulsif trop sanguin
alors vous avez parlé vraiment des
violences conjugales il ya une vidéo sur
les réseaux sociaux qui a fait
énormément parler c'est un internaute
qui a filmé une scène à genève d'un mari
hors de lui qui frappe sa femme avec son
ordinateur
cette vidéo bien sûr indigné tout le
monde on comprend pourquoi regarder
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
voilà ça c'est vraiment c'est un abruti
fini je voyais le docteur jean paul
hamon qui regardaient ça était dépité
jean paul geai rien j'ai rien vu j'ai
entendu j'imaginais la scène
malheureusement malheureusement on sait
que ces choses-là existe des à poitiers
partout et et que les femmes sont pas
sont pas suffisamment protégés
merci je voudrais vraiment à ce que tu
as un truc ajoutée ou le renseigner sur
le confident ce qui peut rendre fou
égérie florence déjà quand on est seul
dans la vie en général on est encore
plus seul quand on est confiné
donc il faut vraiment vraiment qu'on
développe soutien aux personnes qui sont
isolées comme les personnes âgées
notamment
est ce que pour une personne âgée à en
sortir sa rythme est un peu sa vie de
classe ii y avoir un grand pays comme on
peut pas sortir bas au moins passer un
maximum de coups de fil est très
présente
je pense au gouvernement a déjà mis en
place un numéro de soutien au niveau
psychique au vrai ment le développer
seul y avoir beaucoup de retomber
merci laurence